live of get again at the 11th annual Los
Angeles Times Festival of Books taking
place this weekend on the campus of UCLA
book TV is bringing you eight and a half
hours of live coverage starting shortly
Martin Luther King biographer Taylor
branch author of at Canaan's edge he'll
discuss his trilogy on the civil rights
leader with Tavis Smiley and then at
7:00 Eastern a panel of authors from
conflict zones Laurie beckylyn on Iraq
Roxanne Dunbar Ortiz on Nicaragua and
Luong on Cambodia it's live from UCLA
the Los Angeles Times festival books on
book TV our live coverage continues
tomorrow as well at 1:30 Eastern 10:30
Pacific authors Joyce Appleby Martin
Dugard and Sean Wilentz will discuss
their books on early American history at
2:30 call in and talk with journalist
Robert Scheer who's covered every
president since Nixon and at 3:00 p.m.
Eastern Robert Scheer joins a panel with
Mark dinner Scott Ritter and John Ark
Willa to consider the Iraq war three
years after the the invasion John our
quillo will then take your phone calls
his new book is called the Reagan
imprint ideas an American foreign policy
from the collapse of communism to the
war on terror and then at 4:30 Eastern
personal stories from Iraq with John
Crawford author of the last true story
I'll ever tell Paul Rykov author of
chasing ghosts and Evan Wright the
author race author of a Generation Kill
finally tomorrow Colin and talked with a
Quang fom who writes about his father a
South Vietnamese Air Force pilot and
himself a u.s. Marine and Gulf War
veteran his books called sense of duty
that's tomorrow from Los Angeles
starting shortly here today Tavis Smiley
will be speaking with Taylor branch
you're watching live coverage of the Los
Angeles Times Festival of Books on
c-span tooth book TV
if you're just joining us we're live at
UCLA for the 11th annual Los Angeles
Times Book Festival and in just a few
minutes we're going to hear from Tavis
Smiley he's going to be speaking with
author Taylor branch biographer Martin
Luther King and his latest in the
trilogy is called at canons edge that's
scheduled to get underway now we'll have
it live for you once it gets started
obviously now the festival books goes on
today Saturday and also tomorrow really
got underway last night with the
awarding of their annual book prizes
winners last night included Anthony
Shadid Adam Hochschild Gabriel Garcia
Garcia Marquez and Hilary Sperling and a
Lifetime Achievement Award for Joan
Didion who's a biography won a number of
her whose nonfiction work this year won
a number of awards as well again we're
waiting for Tavis Smiley
in a panel with Taylor branch looking at
the life of Martin Luther King jr.
first of all la let's see spanner how
much we love reading books on the west
coast
fëanor uh after Taylor appeared on our
TV show a few weeks ago in the book
first came out he asked what I thought
of is coming out to be part of the Book
Festival I don't know if I can draw a
crowd in LA will people come engage in
this conversation about the life and
legacy of dr. King and I have always
appreciated the fact that through my
public radio program on my public
television program I get a chance as
often as we can most nights on our PBS
show which by the way is the first show
in the history of PBS to imitate live
from the West Coast and my public radio
show the first public radio show in the
history of public radio to broadcast
live on the west coast I'd say I take
that seriously because it's important
for me on behalf of all of those of us
who live and work here in the greater LA
community to let the world know that
intellectual rigor intellectual pursuits
are not a wholly owned subsidiary of the
eastern seaboard and so on
on the west coast on the west coast we
have something to say about important
matters as well and so we always are
pleased to welcome persons on our show
scene across the country but emanating
live from the west coast every night on
PBS always pleased to have authors like
Taylor branch who come to share in
dialogue with us let me before I going
to further ask you to give a warm la
welcome to Pulitzer prize-winning author
Taylor Brown
are
let me apologize briefly to those
watching around the country for that
matter around the world on c-span a
couple of housekeeping matters I have to
share right quickly those in the room
and we'll jump right to our conversation
with Taylor branch first of all there'll
be a book signing immediately following
this session the book signing for this
panel is located at the south signing
area at line-x
the south signing area at line-x it's
noted on your festival maps we'll be
there in just about an hour or so from
now immediately following this session a
book signing with Taylor branch and
yours truly at the South signing area at
line-x I don't have a copy of my text in
front of me but I'm pleased to announce
that I am the editor and compiler of the
number one paperback nonfiction book in
America right now hit number one last
week in the New York Times it is it is
called the Covenant with black America
the Covenant with black America I see
you hold that up back there oh there you
guys a copy right here that right there
the number one book number one paperback
nonfiction book in all of America hit
the New York Times marking at number one
last Sunday and I'm told we are again at
number one this coming Sunday that be
tomorrow so for those who are interested
in what this covenant with black America
is all about the first time essentially
since dr. King speaking of King Taylor
the first time since King was
assassinated that black America has a
has had a guide print a blue a gameplan
a guide book a blueprint if you will for
how we make black America better how do
we at this particular stage in America
do our part to help make America a
nation that is as good as its promise I
saw the American people want I think
nothing more nothing less just a nation
that is as good as its promise and what
Taylor's book underscores I think
dramatically which we'll get to now here
in this conversation is that the black
struggle for freedom and deep democracy
has always din that very same struggle
for America it is the black community
certainly under dr. King's leadership
that challenged America to live up to
her true ideals and so now some 38 years
after King's assassination what does
Amerika have to say about the role that
it can play to make black America better
and I believe and we argue in this text
that when you make black America better
you make all of America better I might
add this is the first book in the
history the first book in the history of
the country the first book in the
history of black people the first book
in the history of the New York Times
list the first black non-fiction book
ever to hit number one on the New York
Times bestseller list was a piece of
history and Taylor and I will be sitting
side by side for a little while signing
copies of you'll be signing his book of
course at canons age and I'll be signing
copies of the Covenant again the South
signing area at line-x no personal
tapings of the session is allowed that's
why c-span sirplease thinks he's paying
for covering this on the west coast
she's family thank you no late for this
announcement no food or drinks in the
window I'm out the window no food or
drinks in the room a little late for
that and please turn off your cell
phones and your pagers so that we are
not disrupted during our conversation oh
you think you turned it off just
double-check right quick to ensure that
it is in the off position and we will
jump into our conversation with Taylor
branch for those who watch our show we
would call this a shameless plug late
night on PBS Monday through Friday
nights 11 o'clock here in Los Angeles
shameless plug for those who watch our
show you know that we had the pleasure
of having Taylor branch featured as a
guest on our show just some weeks ago in
the book came out as I mentioned a
moment ago very seldom that I give the
entire show to one guest Charlie Rose
and I do two types of shows on PBS and
have two different formats two different
styles but it is the occasion every
night again that I will feature someone
for the entire balance of the program
Taylor branch is more than worthy of
that and so we spent the entirety of our
program discussing as best we could at
canons age but I'm glad we have at least
an hour today to jump into a little
deeper conversation and so much stuff
Taylor that we did not cover but those
who have the text already you can see it
is a dense text and there's no way in 30
minutes you can do justice to something
that is historic and dense and something
that's powerful
I believe about the greatest American
we've ever produced that's my own
opinion but I think King is the greatest
American we've ever produced we could
debate Lincoln and FDR I believe the
king is the greatest American we've ever
produced but that's my story I'm
sticking to it I didn't write the book
Taylor did let me start though Taylor
with that very point if my assessment is
reading all three parts now of your
trilogy that King was not just a great
American but in my opinion the greatest
American we've ever produced would you
agree with that would you argue me on
that point I'm with you because you know
I mean you can you can talk about
history and positions of power this is a
guy who never held elected office but
given the fact that even late in his
life unless he was leaving a
demonstration he was out in the street
dr. King was still commonly mistaken for
a waiter given the fact that he he was
he came from a culture that was treated
as invisible in that time to serve the
role of modern founding father of
extending Liberty the goal of freedom
that you're talking about is an
extraordinary accomplishment because he
had to play every role that had ever
been invented in American politics and
then some that never had been invented
before he was dealing with all three
branches of government he was a prophet
he was holding together a movement and
he was constantly under threat of death
now I know that some of the founding
fathers you know they all said we'll
hang together we'll we'll stay together
or hang separately and they were under
some danger as well but none of them as
far as I'm concerned faced the the
package of obstacles that the civil
rights movement had to essentially
change the power structure of a great
nation with none of the traditional
tools of politics and so in that view it
make if that's true or even a fraction
of that is true it makes it doubly
tragic in this day of FBI surveillance
and wars in Iraq that we do not have we
do not you
the civil rights movement as a model for
how you foster defend and advance
democracy in the world that our model
we're stuck on the Vietnam model and the
civil rights movement offered us a
fundamentally different model which to
me is why this history is not just dusty
old history that we're trying to
pigeonhole from a bygone era when we put
what we had peculiar seating
arrangements in a small region of the
country this this is urgently about what
freedom is how you advance it who's
responsible for it and where its
strengths lie all the questions that he
answered in a time of terrorism and
lynchings are urgent today in a
different context let me ask you to that
point to that why it is then you think
that we in a contemporary sense do not
embrace the model um you write
brilliantly and passionately obviously
about the point you make now that this
is a model that really does show us how
to advance this notion of making America
a nation that is as good as its promise
why in a contemporary sense do we not
embrace this model and let me ask let me
be blunt is the fact that it is
color-coded
mm-hmm you think part of the rationale
for why those in leadership today don't
embrace the king in notion of advancing
America I don't think there's any
question about that I mean I think that
it's sad and I think that it's more
complicated than that we can get into it
but I certainly wouldn't begin with any
answer other than yes the country is not
ready fully ready certainly most of the
country the atmosphere the zeitgeist of
the country is not ready to treat a
black LED movement as a leader in its
own constitutional process the promise
of America we're the only country
founded on an idea and all of our
history has tested what does it mean you
know does equal citizenship is it
compatible with slavery or the exclusion
of women from the vote or with
segregation or a host of other things
that we've had and black people have
often been at the combustion points of
that test what does our history mean
this is another one of those periods and
so I think it
is color code into the sense that an
awful lot of the politics the dominant
political discourse since the 60s has
been America wanting to say in somewhat
in fear it's somewhat indigestion
somewhat in adjustment that's not my
story
that's not our story this is when
politics went off the rails this is when
we fought a war against poverty and
poverty won this government and politics
became the problem the dominant idea in
politics since the 60s has been that
government is bad at least when applied
to the purposes of the civil rights
period it's going to screw up and
imprison people now the fact of the
matter is that's not so
empirically that's not so but it
obscures our understanding of how much
freedom we take for granted from this
whole era that our that our political
discourse has been so skewed that's one
reason why I don't put a lot of argument
in this book I think we have a history
in America of distorting our history
particularly with regard to race we did
it in reconstruction after the end of
the Civil War so that I grew up in the
south being taught that the Civil War
had nothing to do with slavery and at
most slaves were happier here as slaves
and they had been in Africa
that's because white America North and
South found something that they could
agree they agreed that that was more
comfortable to believe than what the
truth was
and I think we've having a small part of
that same story now about the 1960s was
at a time when freedom was advanced was
at a time when a black LED movement was
was was really in leading the works in
the laboratory of freedom yes it was and
it is part of our story and and I think
that there's a lot of color-coded
resistance i I will say on the other
hand of that though Tavis I think it's
also true that some of the veterans from
the civil rights era are reluctant to
lay claim to the breadth of the freedom
that was let loose then because it would
diminish it as a purely black
achievement as something for
four-by-four and about and only about
black people and
so I'm not trying to shy away from
controversy here I think that we've had
a frozen defensive attitude toward the
60s and it is at our peril we have
denigrated public service because
because public service is what brought
this freedom and we were frightened of
it and then when we turn around and we
need public service in Katrina what do
we have we have you know horse track
owners running it because all of our
public servants has been stuffed with
people who didn't believe in the mission
of their own government but that's not
just one president that's two
generations of reaction about this I'm
fascinated
and since you you're not afraid of
controversy God knows I'm not let's just
go for live won't cease pretend no less
when you say that when you lay some fall
at the feet of those veterans to use
your word the veterans of the civil
rights movement for not embracing the
depth and breadth of this movement in a
contemporary sense what do you mean by
that you lost me on there that if if you
well actually there are several
different aspects of SEO on books last
night we got to talking about Stokely
just purely about Stokely what is our
attitude about Stokely and and and his
legacy but even before that you don't
see many people from the movement going
around to question two statements number
one non-violence
you can argue historically and I believe
with great truth set in motion most of
the change that we take for granted not
only for ending terrorism and formal
segregation for black people but also
for women for for white people for the
whole country but it was the first idea
to become passé from the movement and it
has not been discussed very
significantly in the in the 40 years
since there are a lot of people from the
movement who are embarrassed today that
they were nonviolent I will say that the
controversy so I've had people insist
that they weren't when I had tapes of
him introducing dr. King they said
that's not me so why would they be
embarrassed now that they were
nonviolent particularly given that it
works so well because
it has become part of the water that we
drink just like it's part of the water
that we drink in politics that
government is bad that non-violence was
a kiddie stage of politics that it was
the politics of weakness and that we had
to be nonviolent because we were just
black people back then and we were
segregated and these arguments that dr.
King had with Stokely in them are living
in your gut arguments about what's
creative in history and Stokely
essentially said why is it that America
admires non-violence only in black
people otherwise they admire James Bond
and you know John Wayne and you know
rough tough white guys but they liked
non-violence and black people because it
makes them feel safe and so that's not
that's not right so why is it that the
people who have suffered the denial of
their rights have to seek out further
sacrifice in order to get everybody else
to do what they should have done in the
first place that's not fair and dr. King
pleaded with Stokely come to my church
I'm going to preach on that of course
it's not fair this is a leadership
doctrine for the whole country it's not
that black people in non-violence are
behind or children or or or behind their
normal role of being as violent as
everybody else it's that they're ahead
you know non-violence is the
democratization of the country so that
we if we fall away from non-violence
which we're put fully entitled to do
there's no obligation that we do that
we're we are we are owed the thanks of
history and of every American for what
we're doing but if we fall back from
non-violence we are retreating back to
the same sorry-sorry violent cycle that
dominates most of history and so that's
the argument that they had also dr. King
of course said you know we need to lay
claim for all of the freedom that we set
loose and he said this prophetically at
a time we have to remember America was
still mostly segregated even in the
formal ways that I mean college
basketball was still segregated if he
turned on TV on Saturday before he was
killed to watch basketball in March of
1968 he would see all white players now
now so a lot of things that we take for
granted weren't there then but he's
saying this movement is going to
liberate not just black people in the
south from segregation it's going to
liberate the white South it is
they are so invested and paralyzed in an
enforcing segregation that you can't
even have a business meeting in the
south it wasn't fit for professional
sports teams you didn't have any
professional sports in the south the
mayor of Atlanta said as soon as they
sign the civil rights bill we built a
stadium on land we didn't own with money
we didn't have for a team we hadn't
found and with and within a few months
they got the Atlanta Braves and they and
they created the Atlanta Atlanta Falcons
and they created the Miami Dolphins he's
saying we need to lay claim you know you
never heard of the Sun Belt when it was
segregated
it was the hookworm belt we were very
poor and we had one-party ossified
politics of segregationist Democrats now
we have two-party competition at least
in the south we liberated southern white
politicians but you'll never hear Bill
Frist say I'm standing on the shoulders
of Fannie Lou Hamer because I be I can
be the majority leader of the US Senate
because we are no longer stigmatized by
the moral stain of segregation so dr.
King is saying we liberated all these
people and women too he was he had a
chauvinist streak he wasn't as good on
that but he certainly got lectured by
the women in the movement who would say
you know the principles of equal
citizenship they that you are setting
loose and proclaiming as the essence of
freedom they will soon be applied and
they soon are applied to things that we
take for granted that women can go to -
most of the private colleges in the
United States that they couldn't go to
before that a lot of public universities
a lot of professions that are open that
they can serve on juries one of the
stories I have in here women by law
could not serve on juries of any race in
the whole state of Alabama until one of
the Ku Klux Klan murders in the Civil
Rights Movement
got Pauli Murray one of my heroines to
file a lawsuit to overturn that statute
women were restricted to serve on juries
across this country the prevailing
Supreme Court decision was Hoyt V
Florida which held that if you were a
Florida female and he wanted to serve on
a jury you had to go down to the
courthouse and swear out an affidavit
saying I want to be considered for jury
duty and it won't interfere with my
homemaking duties now that's how
stratified our society was before the
movement started struggling with so all
these freedoms come from the movement
Justice Alito just the other day got
confirmed the other week he could barely
remember that he was against admitting
female students to Princeton why can he
barely remember it because he's on the
wrong side of history okay but he's on
the wrong side of a history that was set
in motion by the civil rights movement
2,000 years of rabbinic Judaism you've
never had a female rabbi until they
started struggling over what equal souls
mean and the context of equal votes and
the civil rights movement and you have
the first female rabbi ordained in 1972
and Pauli Murray herself at the age of
almost seventy became the first female
Episcopal priest in 1976 this is
somebody who had been a lawyer
struggling she invented the term Jane
crow saying these same principles apply
so all this freedom that we take for
granted I'm saying not just Bill Frist
stands on the shoulders of this movement
but the parent of every daughter in this
room has opportunities that we take for
granted that we really owe to the civil
rights
so we're not willing to say by and large
that's our story that freedom is is my
freedom too and some people in the
movement are not willing to say the
freedom that we were about has is a gift
to the world at large because because
they're worried about holding it for
themselves I could sit in this I could
sit listen to you talk hours ad nauseam
the problem with that is the longer I
let you go the more backed up I get on
things I want to you can go as long as
this is your conversation but I'm saying
on a serious note that you've said so
much that I want to come back and pick
right on now all right if I might to
pick apart some of that and at about a
half an hour from now you want to leave
10 to 15 minutes at the end for audience
questions and these microphones I'll let
you know when we get to that in about 30
32 minutes from now let me just go back
to what you said now and pick a couple
things apart right quick and move
through as I can you mentioned that King
had a chauvinist streak that was a nice
way of putting that it was very
ambassadorial of you to say they had a
chauvinist streak they already occurred
to me tailors you mentioned that that
while King had a chauvinist streak he
could not have done what he did
without women and indeed you dedicate
the last book in this trilogy to Diane
Nash so let's step away from King for
just a second and talk about women
particularly in the presence of the
woman you dedicate this book to Diane
Nash and who she was what her role was
well actually parting the waters is
dedicated to septum--ah Clark it is
indeed women Diane of course she's a
heartstrings story for me yeah I think
she she's from Chicago she's living in
dire circumstances in Chicago even this
day she's not really well appreciated
anywhere near the degree she should be
she was in the Nashville nonviolent
movement with John Lewis and Jim bevel
and Marion Barry and and Jim Lawson was
their leader at Ct Vivian and all these
people who became the heart of the snick
and the nonviolent movement she invented
herself at least three or four historic
expansions of the term movement the
Freedom Rides
before that the first sit-in where she
went to another
to go to jail in another town when it
was already absolutely revolutionary for
students to go to jail people couldn't
absorb the notion of young people taking
that kind of risk and she did she
expanded and said the movement in rocket
same of us I'm going there and served 30
30 days then in the freedom ride she
expanded it she said the adult freedom
riders cannot be allowed to go home we
students have to go and take it up for
them and turn the Freedom Rides into an
international phenomenon in the summer
of 61 then she and her husband bevel the
most unlikely couple you'll ever meet
they were the ones primarily arguing to
take the supreme risk of Kings career
which was to use small children and the
demonstrations in Birmingham which set
off arguments in every black household
there that this was not just not just
wrong that this was insane to use
ten-year-old children how does a woman
suggest that Taylor back then no less
Diane bevel used to tell me asked me if
I'd seen the movie of African Queen he
said if you if you saw the movie African
Queen and you know how the leeches got
on Humphrey Bogart when he got down in
the river and he was jumping right he
said that's the way Diane would get on
you and she she got on them not even
finish their Mother's Day picnic
celebrating
a campaign to integrate the the movie
theaters of Nashville but because the
berming because the Freedom Riders have
been buses had been burned and she says
we got to go down there in sable and
then she also got on King after the
Birmingham church bombing the night of
the Birmingham church bombing by the
next morning she wrote up a plan to
answer it by saying if black we want to
create a non-violent army to stop
paralyzed Alabama until it grants the
right that black people the right to
vote here that became the blueprint for
selma and she went and pestered king for
a year and a half until he did this he
said diane we we've been fighting for a
decade on segregation we can't tell the
country time out you know diane wants to
focus on voting rights in alabama we
can't do that
she said when people are willing to die
leadership has to give them an outlet
and people were that upset over the
Birmingham church bonding so this is a
person who took it on herself and this
is what's so remarkable to be not to
write a letter not to blame somebody not
to say somebody else ought to do
something about this not to say well
gosh it ought to at least be somebody
with a lot of money who can vote some
white person should do something about
it she said I can't even vote myself in
Alabama but I'm gonna have a plan to fix
that and to answer this heinous crime
and once when I was talking to Diane
about J Edgar Hoover and something
terrible that he had done to the student
movement because the FBI didn't harass
just dr. King and she said don't talk to
me about Hoover Hoover is our fault and
I said what do you mean I was stunned by
this she said well we left him in a
position of arbitrary power for 50 years
and anybody who knows the slightest bit
about the American system should know
that we got just what we deserved and we
expected it the American citizens did
that and and what's so striking about
that is that she takes responsibility
for the whole country even the parts of
it that she didn't have anything to do
with and she says that's the beginning
of a citizen's movement you know if you
believe that we're all equally
responsible for what's going on in Iraq
or anywhere the first thing you got to
do is act like it and it's for that
sense of citizenship
that's so sadly overlooked see because I
think if we had a better country not as
bounded by race as we do that Diane Nash
would be upheld there'd be you know
statues over you mention the Birmingham
I was at a private gathering that a
number of black leaders and veterans
from the movement you were there that
day in Atlanta
yeah the Harry Belafonte thing I
couldn't get to her fast enough to
introduce myself to her I just just met
her with in the same room that Taylor
was in just but five months ago yes we
just met her for the first time
fascinating too to meet her that said um
you mentioned a couple things
the Birmingham church bombing which
really got her pardon the phrase on you
know on fire about this particular issue
of voting rights and going after getting
dr. King to respond to it I was reminded
rereading your text here in this trilogy
that King was such a stoic brother that
he never really showed his emotions in
public now you read your text you find
out that he was extremely emotional and
had bouts with depression and a variety
of other things we'll get to maybe in
the time we have left
but what's what I was reminded of
reviewing the text is that the only time
on record that we ever see dr. King cry
in public is that the Birmingham church
service yes where King speaks and his
emotions get the best of him in the only
time in recorded history that we see
this stoic leader cry in public I raised
that only because you mentioned the
Birmingham church bombing reminded me of
that but in a larger context what did it
do to him to be preaching this message
of non-violence went on occasions like
the 16th Street Baptist Church in
Birmingham everything he said he found
himself out of crossroads trying to
consider whether or not he was in fact
on point and as you well know every time
he stood up and said non-violence
non-violence non-violence and something
like this happened they would come after
him in the black community for being so
off point yeah yeah I you know I I think
that question Tavis goes to the to the
to the quality of his voice if you
listen to King you can if you could
scramble the word so that you didn't
even hear the words before you
understand any of the words it seems to
me that what really reaches out and
grabs you is the war in his voice
between a head
zhan unflinching realism about how bad
things are in a time of lynching when
these four little girls can get bombed
when the guy got executed for stealing a
dollar and thirty cents right after the
montgomery bus boycott he did this and
even at the end of his life people
weren't sure that all the gains and the
promises weren't gonna recede again so
to offer hope and in the midst of that
realism that depression and that sense
of being in a crucible where he's being
torn apart even by his own staff to me
is the real essence of King his voice is
like I call it a wood stove because he's
got the realism of how bad things are
and and he's fighting against it to
project some sort of some sort of
victory some sort of hope in the midst
of it and if and if he doesn't
acknowledge how bad things are then he
sounds Pollyannish and if he gives in to
despair then you don't hear any hope and
he he's right on that edge and I think
that's what makes his voice so arresting
um you mentioned a moment ago and we did
not get a chance to get to this in our
television conversation before on PBS so
I'm glad that we can get to get to this
now and c-span here this whole notion of
equal souls and equal rights mm-hmm
my dear friend Cornel West Princeton
professor and I were together the other
day and we had a fascinating debate
about this and I wish West were here now
so that we can all go at this and kind
of recreate that conversation but I'm
not so certain that I'm altogether
convinced of that branching notion of
equal Souls equal rights can you talk
about that a little bit I first noticed
it actually as a as a pattern in his in
his oratory that he so regularly would
offer a paired phrase you know we will
win our freedom because the heritage of
our nation and the eternal will of God
are eko eko and embodied in our echoing
demands or in the letter from Birmingham
jail one day the South will know that
when these disinherited children of God
sat in at lunch counters they were in
reality
ending up for the best in the American
creed and for the most sacred values of
our judeo-christian heritage and when he
got together with Heschel Abraham
Heschel in Chicago this this was really
something for the from the second volume
for me their their point of contact was
Heschl's belief that the prophets that
the Hebrew prophets by holding Kings
accountable for the way they treated
widows and orphans were proclaiming that
there were equal Souls before God and
that that idea in ancient history is the
precursor for our notion of equal votes
equal Souls and equal votes and that
we're equal not in the sense that we
have the same attainments or the same
height or the same skills but that we
count our votes the same that's there's
an essence there and that our souls are
the same and so King was trying to draw
on on both of these and and so he has
this pattern in his rhetoric of putting
one foot in the Constitution or the
dekor in patriotic principles and the
other in the scripture and tying him
into this notion of equal souls and
equal votes and to me it is a gift of
rhetoric and this is one way this is how
I think of it I think it's so remarkable
given the fact that here's a man talking
about religion and politics every day
sometimes four or five speeches and he's
got lots of people who want to kill him
lots of people who resent him lots of
people who want to patronize him and say
you don't have it quite right you know
yes I agree with this dr. King but you
shouldn't have all that he and and his
own staff pulling him apart but there's
not one instance on the record that I
can find that people criticize him for
mixing church and state not once
why how can that be and to me the only
answer to that riddle is that he had a
gift for making it non-threatening he
was not trying to subvert or subdue
religion with politics or politics with
religion he was trying to open a door to
common chambers of inspiration equal
Souls equal votes and that's why to me
he he did make it such a such a pattern
in his oratory to use of civic liberties
symbols of civic freedom where they're
stirring
you know the Gettysburg Address is not a
religious document but it has a
religious fervor to it and so you know
in that sense King and Lincoln were
alike I guess a what did Cornel say we
we ain't got time for that I thought I
took and he used words I didn't quite
understand whenever I talk to dr. West I
have to pull out my dictionary and my
thesaurus Cornell can take you there um
back one last one last follow-up on this
though since that clearly was not this
equal Souls equal rights equal souls
equal votes since that clearly was not
the order of the day at best what King
was talking about was let me let me let
me rephrase this way was King's argument
then that these were inalienable in
alienable rights endowed upon us by our
Creator or was Kings argument more how
might I put an aspirational
disconnection between I think they're
both aspirational I think what he's
saying is that this is what we proclaim
this is this is the goal this is the
intuition as it were but I think
basically he's offering you two doorways
in in there he's saying basically if you
don't care about religion then your
civic heritage is at stake here this is
what makes the flag fly this is what
makes it wave it's you know it's not
that we have lots of soldiers Genghis
Khan had lots of soldiers what makes the
flag wave is our notion of freedom and
he and at the same time he's saying we
have but the inspiration of our religion
is this notion of equal souls before God
which is what makes us brothers and
sisters and what makes non-violent not
non-violence not only a religious but a
political idea how did that argument
stick though how did King make that
argument work and I think you follow me
on this yeah how did King make that
argument work given that at that time
and I'm not so sure things are very
different today the leaders were putting
the flag above the cross you're trying
to connect to things here but they're
flying the flag they're raising the flag
even above the cross so how did he make
that argument work does that make sense
you thought my name's trying to say that
we need to raise our politics up to the
level of the cross and and that and that
you will know when some
if somebody is trying to is trying to
invoke supreme values in politics unless
they're speaking the values of the cross
then they're likely phony and to me
that's obvious today if you got somebody
calling themselves a religious leader
saying you know that they want to kill
people and there's something wrong
there's something wrong with this
picture but nobody nobody says anything
about it I think people without a
spiritual bone in their body can claim
to be religious leaders but you know
Kings showed that you have to be some
sort you have to have some sort of
consistency and I and and and that's
what makes it his voice so authentic
that's what made all kinds of people
able to react to his voice and his
message even when they didn't appreciate
where the politics was going or were
frightened by it that's what I that that
unnamed person in the White House that
you referenced a moment ago shall shall
remain unnamed but I suspect if he were
on this panel today his response might
be or at least the response of his brain
mr. Rove might be yeah Taylor but King
never met this guy named Osama bin Laden
uh-huh and had he been around in the
time of a guy named bin Laden
then his non-violence might have been
checked that have to be checked at the
door yeah we have that argument all the
time and and King used to make make
speeches about that you know what what
should i do what should I say to Castro
or to all these or to Ho Chi Minh cuz
those were the same things in that day
he would say can I threaten them with
death or should not I not visit them
with my life shouldn't not our model be
what Abe Lincoln said when he was when
he was ordered to be more peremptory in
executing southerners he said do I not
destroy my enemies when I make them my
friend you have to have some sort of
witness for your own system which is one
why one reason why I think King would
say that our strength is in our values
and the moment you say that we have to
give up our values in order to be strong
you are tacitly saying that our strength
is not in our values and in it from that
moment you have already lost the
argument for the world
so what he would be for and I'm not you
know King the sadness that we don't have
trials that we don't have our give our
enemies even in the war on terrorism the
right is not only is not only
politically sadness but it makes us
weaker and whoever said trials are for
sissies you know we want to we want to
you know we're going to show these
people what they're made of
is it's not just a formula to be
incompetent and ineffective it's a
formula to be weaker in the world and so
I'm not saying they're not really hard
choices here what King often said was
what we really have to worry about and
be attuned to is what is our appetite
what are we trying to say if we're
making a judgement that only violence
will work in this one sense when the
guys broken in my house my children are
there and he's pointing a gun at him you
know that's one thing but he said most
of these arguments really invent these
situations from an appetite to justify
violence and if you can examine your
heart and you're not having an appetite
to justify violence that's one thing but
you know to have an appetite to justify
things that go against your values is
the formula definition for cynicism one
of the things that we learn again
reading your work is that were this
nonviolent notion is concerned which is
always fascinating me whether it's
notion of non-violence kinging and
non-violence has referred to it is
concern it was really his now dearly
departed wife Coretta Scott King who
pushed him in ways that most persons who
are not knowledgeable who've not read
your work don't really get certainly
after the bombing of their house in
Montgomery this goes back a ways in the
trilogy but it was Martin who suggested
that maybe he should have some armed
guards stand at their house to protect
Coretta and the kids here's the guy who
gave us this notion of non-violence but
talk for a moment about back to women
and their role in the movement it was
Coretta who really introduced him and
pushed him on this notion of
non-violence yes yes Coretta
a peace activist as far back as Antioch
College if not before and there were a
lot of times where he as he developed
non-violence out of the Montgomery bus
boycott it did evolve from just
something that is part and parcel of the
pulpit and justified I will confess my
naive and patronizing attitude when I
started this was that maybe Martin
Luther King was somebody who got carried
away with the notion of turn the other
cheek and stumbled into to the movement
but you know then you start studying and
you see what a wrestle it was for him
even to go into the ministry and to
study all this and then to absorb Gandhi
in non-violence in American terms and
and to define it and refine it and to
fashion it as a political tool a prophet
using a political tool out of
non-violence in the context of American
freedom where he learned from Coretta is
that this applies to issues far beyond
purely the race issue because you know
Coretta was a peace activist in war and
said these are the same issues and you
hear that in the most overlooked sadly
overlooked of King's major addresses his
Nobel Prize speech when he says that
non-violence is a tool of democracy that
can be applied the world over against
the triple scourge of racism war and
poverty violence of the flesh and
violence of the Spirit and the
non-violence if we understand what we
you know the forces of what we can
create between us as a weapon against
all of those and Coretta was very very
instrumental in helping him expand it
beyond the notion of race and see it as
a construct that could apply to to the
whole of human history and on the on the
movement don't one thing I'll say about
the movement dr. King knew that the
movement went on on the labors of women
there never would have been a movement
without women he knew that he what I
meant by the chauvinist part and I'm not
getting into the private life unless you
want to go there but what I meant by the
Chauvin will go there about two seconds
ago hark what I'm what I meant by this
chauvinist part is that women are
leaders as long as there is not a
microphone and he was very comfortable
with that with the spokesperson role
with the note you know Pauli Murray whom
I mentioned earlier she was the only one
who had the guts to protest that the
march on Washington had no female
speakers in a movement that is
self-consciously struggling for equal
access and what it means on the race
issue but they even made the women march
down a different Street
so her protest notwithstanding the only
one who got to the microphone that day
though it was as you know my hell you
Jackson yeah and she was singing she was
singing right spiit other person alive
just one question about that only
because when the text came out and Time
magazine yes did the excerpts from it
the thing is you know that everybody
seized on of course Jesse Jackson was
not was none too happy with you for the
things you said about him in the book
that's another issue but the thing that
everybody outside of Jesse seized on was
the excerpt the time chose to run of
Kings confession to Coretta of his
philandering at a time when she had just
had a major surgery tell me how
difficult it is to come across these
facts in your research and to put that
out there knowing that there are people
who got have a issue with that and
particularly african-american people who
might somehow read that and think that
here's a guy who is trying to not keying
down a peg or to to denigrate this great
black icon well I do struggle with that
I yes there's no issue that you struggle
harder on but it's not really for me an
issue of that particular one it's which
fact to present what is fair what is
fair to the readers who are not going to
be blindsided by the truth later you
know how to be selective and fair to be
represented in the whole mix of his life
now after all I'm not a biographer I
don't take the from the very beginning I
I don't take the biographers burden to
explain every heartbeat of your subject
I'm trying to talk about King and the
movement I called it a metaphor Kings at
the center of the movement and the
movement is at the center of freedom and
I won't want to sustain that that's why
I called it the King years you know
everybody else calls it some some other
years I call it the King years which is
where we started a TV show and I think
just for those who didn't see the show
that I thank you for that it's
courageous of someone to look at this
period in our history and speaking of I
don't want cut y'all come right back to
that but speaking of getting America to
understand the significance of the
movement and what black folk through
this struggle for again deep democracy
and justice and freedom to get all of
America to understand what that means
and how we ought to emulate this model
somebody has to have the courage and the
conviction and the commitment to
reformulate to shift and create a new
paradigm for how we reference these
years it's part of my English these
ain't the Kennedy years you know these
are the King years it was King forcing
this nation to live up to its true ideal
and that's why I think she was the start
of our conversation for even naming in
all of these three texts referring to
this period as the King years and I
thank you again here on c-span that's it
finishing them
if if you're going to hold the FBI
accountable for its crimes and this
dishonours and its lies then then you've
got to present a balanced picture about
the allegations that they have as well
it seems to me if you're going to be
fair-minded I had a much harder time
Tavis was talking about the dr. King's
confession this was born out of many
arguments toward the end of his life
when he was depressed when he was even
seeking help what do I do some the
notion of confessing the fact that is
that his marriage hadn't been perfect to
his wife was something that he recoiled
from to put it mildly and so for him to
do that to me I thought was very
poignant that he changed his mind on
that so near the end of his life but did
it in such a ham-handed way that it to
me it was a telling detail that he
wouldn't think that maybe this wasn't
the best time you know that anybody else
would understand what this meant to a
woman his wife to go through that and
then he should he should have if he's
going to confess he should have done a
different time to me that it was a
humanizing thing I had a much harder
time with myself putting in some earlier
details that nobody has really mentioned
so I think a lot of this is is um its
skewed is what people notice having to
do with the fact that people presented
themselves to him through inner
intermediaries that that he had people
that his own brother you know asked
somebody to come to his room recruiting
somebody who became his mistress and I
only put that in there because I had
other people tell satisfying me that
this was not an isolated incident but I
only put that one thing in there to give
people a sense of what the life is like
on the fly running between the death
threats and the movements and and all
that sort of thing but there's a wealth
of information in the one story that I
heard enough
to believe not from the FBI but from the
people themselves is true that his this
is a this is a star's life on the run
and that people are actually offering
themselves and recruiting themselves for
people for him that was hard for me
because that is an alien an alien world
to me but I think that it's real it's an
alien world of stars on the road for me
and and and it doesn't go down well with
with my view of you know Kings place in
history let me offer this as an exit
question for my pilot program and then
we'll take we'll get to c-span to give
us a few extra minutes here which I'm
sure they will and we'll give you a
chance for about 10 minutes or so to ask
any quick questions or comments about
mr. branch's work the extra question
takes me back to the very beginning of
this conversation and I raised this
again only because this was said to me
by Andy Young in the context of this
book that I that I've edited and
compiled being number one this week on
the on the bestseller list this it'll
make it'll make sense in just a second
it'll make sense in a second so I'm
talking to Andy Young the other day
obviously one of the kings in a circle
and Andy calls me Andy young calls me to
congratulate me on the book getting to
number one and the context of the
conversation he's saying to me as he
said any number times Taylor I wish you
and King I wish you'd been around which
had been born earlier so that you and
King could have gotten to know each
other and work together and he's heard
me say any number of times as you've
heard me say one of the regrets of my
young life is that I wasn't around to
meet this guy who I so reverence but
Andy called to make the point to me that
what King never had was a radio show hmm
I told you if you stay with me you'd get
this so it was not about my book King
never had a radio show King never had a
television show indeed the largest
audience King ever spoke to was in fact
the march on Washington the largest
audience in his life that he ever spoke
to I'm talking to millions of people on
television every day talking to millions
of folk on radio every day this book the
Covenant made it to number one without
being featured on Oprah without being on
The Today Show without being on NPR and
all the
covering the book have made a big deal
about hi gods number one with all of
that exposure the point is that it went
to number one because every day black
people have been talking about it and
going out and getting a copy of the book
I raised that because I look at all that
King accomplished in his life in an era
when people didn't want to hear what he
had to say and he's a black man he
doesn't have any media he doesn't have
radio he doesn't have television he
doesn't have internet and we think about
movements today there is no movement in
the country today that does not embrace
all of those forms of communication
television print radio and now internet
I close with this how did this guy end
up making such I guess the central
question is how did he do it how do you
make this kind of monumental
contribution without I just can't fathom
how you do all of this without all of
these resources that we have today to
get the message out about the meeting
how are we gonna do this what the plan
is what the agenda is here's what time
we gonna meet how do you pull off
something this monumental to make this
nation a better nation without having
any access to all the stuff that we have
access to now Kings book never got to
number one no never got to them and yet
none of them and yet this guy becomes
the icon I think when you talk about
freedom and justice in this country how
did he do it
and in that context on his book the
subtitle strive toward freedom a leader
of his people talks about the Montgomery
bus boycott
he wasn't even present it in books as of
a fellow American he was presented as
you know this so my answer to your
question is that the first reality we
have to understand is that he became the
spokesperson for a Citizens movement
that didn't wait for spokespeople people
from all over the country who had been
percolating about what they could do
about freedom and the sit-ins and
everything he was the what made him
unique was he was the only adult leader
who said these young people have found a
form a breakthrough in
history for the biggest problem that I
have which is that sometimes things are
so stubborn in human nature that words
alone are not enough you've got to
magnify it with sacrifice and that's
what the sit-ins were so I think that
the the way he did it without all of
these advantages of modern communication
was that he became a spokesperson for a
movement that was already ignited in and
among citizens who weren't gonna wait
and the really significant thing is that
from time and time again in Selma
Birmingham the Freedom Rides when the
call went out and he articulated what it
was after Selma bridge he asked for
people to come and not to write a letter
not to call the White House not to send
in a contribution but to come not next
week not next month but to come tomorrow
and stand with the people who were
beaten for the right to vote the most
precious thing in democracy in Selma and
they did so that's kind of leadership
but he could only do that in the context
of a Citizens movement where people came
from Massachusetts they came from Hawaii
they came from Chicago nuns came from
st. Louis and went home and started talk
radio because 40,000 people call them
why did nuns go down there and risk
getting killed in Selma 1965 it was a
Citizens movement he was for a
combination of reasons a great tactical
leader but primarily a magnificently
chosen voice for what I think is the
inspirational message of equal souls and
equal votes not only the best heritage
that we have spiritually but the
enduring message that we have
politically and he said for the whole
country you know I believe that the goal
of America is freedom however much she
strays from it and we've strayed a lot
from it now before we go to your
questions right quick let me ask you to
thank the LA Times Festival of Books for
making mr. Branch available to us today
I'll say this time you have a quick
question to comment rare opportunity to
speak to Taylor branch directly your
quick question to comment there use two
microphones right here just step to them
you just got a few minutes and then
we'll tell you again where the book
signing is I want to add my
congratulations to you for being number
one if you hadn't noticed that that's a
wonderful that's a wonderful thing and I
only my book is only that fat because I
put 200 pages of footnotes in there so
Oprah wouldn't think it was a novel
alright I think this is probably all
we're gonna have time to take right here
so if you're not in line now just stop
and we probably won't get past all these
give me a quick question or comment
we'll give mr. branch's response yes
ma'am
yeah just a quick one you talked about
dr. King being a tremendous catalyst for
the sweeping social changes that
happened in the 60s and I look at the
situation in the country today where we
have the slaughter of tens of thousands
of innocent people going on we have an
administration that thinks the
Constitution is toilet paper and yet
there's no moral outrage I mean do we
need another dr. King to sort of
catalyze some type of movement well I
think that I would just I can answer
that in the sentence I think that
empirically speaking our conditions if
you go back are much better than we take
for we take a lot of things for granted
in our daily lives a lot of freedoms but
that our discourse is worse has
atrophied in the sense that if the
movement was offering hope in a time of
lynchings and and mattefy I was doing in
J Edgar Hoover we have very little
excuse not to be offering more hope and
and offering a more outrage today you
can't talk like Martin Luther King and
govern like Caesar and not have honesty
catch up with you yes sir I wonder if
you could speak for a moment to that
other moment in dr. King's life you
mentioned the Nobel Prize speech but at
the other speech that he gave that goes
neglected it seems to me as the speech
he gave about Vietnam which goes to the
heart of the one of the subjects that
you addressed earlier which was his
representing not only the cause for
African American people but for the
people as a whole and it does seem
in retrospect and even at the time when
he opened up the the conversation to
include Vietnam that's when he became
most pilloried and and abused that one
if you could speak to that reach the
Riverside Church speech exactly one day
before he was killed our whole chapter
on it it's an amazing story how it came
about his advisors were unanimously
against it and dr. King said I I'm going
to do it anyway I promised bevel Diane
Nash's husband who hears voices and is a
prophet and dr. King said of him
it's the cracked ones that let the light
in but he promised Babel he gave this
speech and the New York Times said
basically we don't hear anything you
don't know anything about foreign
affairs you know stick to race relations
that was the most one of the most
painful moments in dr. King's life and
the whole world came down on including
the n-double-a-cp and everybody else so
it was a it was a very very painful
lesson for him that the rest of the
world didn't get the Nobel Prize speech
that his principles applied to larger
things than just segregation preferably
segregation in the south but it's also a
magnificent speech itself I can't get
into it now but if you if you don't know
about the Riverside Church speech it's a
magnificent magnificent articulation of
the relationship between violence and
non-violence in promoting democracy and
there's a lot in that there's a lot in
that I mean dr. King said to mark what's
the hope what what is the atomic
particle power of democracy it's a vote
democracy is you know struct anger
management structured by votes what is a
vote it's a piece of non-violence and so
for him this is this is a very profound
topic that he was trying to apply to
everyday affairs and we didn't get his
message computer first of all no do
difference mr. smiley we expected to see
one of those nice ties that you normally
break I'm sorry
I'll tell you funny story about their
math faculty right quick two second
story I walked in I was surprised to see
him on the front row and this has not
been public information but we taped our
TV shows Laura earlier this week I've
been having some nasal some nasal issues
on some breathing problems and the only
time I could do the surgery which is a
bit intensive was over the last few days
so on Thursday after we finished taping
Thursday morning I went to cedars-sinai
and my three physicians met me there and
for the last three days literally I've
been in the hospital at caesars it
surgery was successful and they let me
come and Taylor didn't even know this I
literally got I was late coming in they
let me out of the hospital two hours ago
to come here to be a part of this
conversation today with Taylor branch
which I told my doctors I cannot miss
Taylor branch but the anesthesiologist
who put me under and brought me out all
right is right here dr. James fruit
trail from cedars-sinai so and he stole
your tie yeah so I gave my child doctor
a trail for bringing me back to life
after putting me under so that's why I'm
tireless anyway thank you your question
mr. Brandt you used the term zeitgeist
and if I understand it correctly is the
ghost of the moment of the time right
what I understood was that Martin and
reading a book to kill a black man
Martin and Malcolm were caught up in
that moment and so what the moment was
looking for with those sorts of talents
that would come to bear on the needs of
the time that being said this seems to
be a time of a new zeitgeist there's
there's an s necessity for something new
do you know any composite
characteristics of someone who can help
bring us out of what we're in now I
would start with you and me and not with
the leader I think that if we you and I
were doing if we were marred then the
leader would come along
that's what I would particularly because
what we're talking about doing is
shifting the guy going against it and
and going against what makes people
comfortable that's what made the
movement so amazing people had to make
spectacles of themselves that's not
natural for people to go to jail if you
were the first college student in the
history of your family and to risk
throwing all that away is going against
it you know Diane Nash told me looking
back on the movement it was like her
wedding day and this is not because she
was married to bevel what she meant by
that was that it was her knees were
knocking she knew she was taking a leap
in the unknown that was really defining
her and that that's what the movement
was like and that's what citizenship
should be and then the leaders will
speak for themselves let me stay
conscious I'm almost finished about on
my one last person Thank You Clark roved
I kept this target from Newsweek since
January 11 1993 because I think it's
very important when Martin Luther King
for preach non-violence many of his
listeners thought he meant inin just
physical violence but he also met
psychological violence education has
never really absorbed that concept
thank you I agree with that and that's
why he was saying in the Nobel Prize
speech that non-violence could be
developed and should be developed as a
tool against racism war and poverty
violence even of the spirit and the
first part of violence of the Spirit is
not to see people is to literally make
people invisible and that's what the
Poor People's Campaign was about the
first step make them fellow human being
so I agree with with her point 100% and
and part of the training of non-violence
was not having just the conservative
discipline self government to be willing
to accept blows but to look in the eye
of somebody out of that same sort of
sense of spirit that you can create
fellow citizenship even in somebody who
hates you and in that sense the
nonviolent movement is an incandescent
example of what makes democracy such a
revolution
notion in history that you can govern
yourself and that you can have build
public trust with strangers that's the
Democratic you know that's what Madison
said it's all about we rest all our
political experiments on the capacity of
mankind for self-government
so the movement is in the heart of
democracy yeah I think there give me the
wraps I let me do this if I can ask
three of you one a time I mean
back-to-back give me your questions
right quick and I'll give Taylor to give
a nice wrap up and pull together yes sir
laws just and unjust
I think Proposition 2 or 9 is an unjust
law the greatest benefit of that law has
been of affirmative action has been
white women and I was wondering what you
could say about what solutions you offer
in this day and time when primitive
actions under attack yes ma'am going on
that there are people in that movement
who think that's the new civil rights
movement and what's your opinion about
that very quick in about 45 seconds you
mentioned Cornel West and I you know I
just finished reading and this has to do
with it how you describe the times how
you characterized the times the most
tumultuous and transformative years in
the history of this country through that
period between nineteen to late 50s
through the 1970s and you know you
mentioned Cornel West and I just
finished reading a memoir that was
written at the suggestion of Cornel West
it's called from Ike to mal my journey
from mainstream America to revolutionary
communist but Bob Avakian and he talks
he was very much involved in a whole
revolutionary edge of things the
Panthers
you know the urban rebellions Malcolm
and it seems to me that it's one thing I
appreciate the biography and I wish we
had hours more to discuss this as well
as a fascinating forum would be actually
gathering together the people that wrote
the articles you have in your book big
pieces and discussing that because
nothing is more needed and there is
leadership out there now and I think
this guy bacon is actually worth
checking out but I think actually I'd
like to hear your why you say that you
would define that error mainly from the
standpoint of non-violence and I don't
think it when there's so much more going
on there was the revolutionary movement
that actually inspired millions here and
around the world I lived in South Africa
for quite a while and one of the things
that inspired the Black Consciousness
movement was Matt was Malcolm and the
Panthers you know and there's and I
think it's actually important to dig
into that because people are looking for
a way out of this and you can't describe
it by virtue of what worked because
frankly look at what's going on today
even standing here the puny number of
black people allowed to go to
universities now the poverty Katrina you
know working is not the question so I
need to know why you described that area
in that way well I just you know my
conclusion after study in this period is
that is that non-violence shoved into
motion most of the positive change that
occurred in that period and that when we
abandoned non-violence of Diane Nash it
was it became so pervasive that non she
said basically after 10 years in
non-violence if I've done all this in
non-violence and set this in motion
think how much we could do if I was
willing to knock over a bank for the
revolution and she said ten years later
I looked up I had knocked over a bank I
hadn't even been to the rifle range and
what I had done is to disengage from the
gut-wrenching change in history behind a
lot of noise and I think to me that her
life is a metaphor for how much we
accomplished by non-violence and open
keen finally what we can be saying about
the aspirations of people of color and
women on the notion of affirmative
action what we can't be saying about
this immigrant rights struggle we
engaged in that well there I would say
the first thing about them is that
they're invisible and that and that a
movement to make them visible so we can
figure out what our relationship and our
dependence is with our fellow human
beings is fully in the spirit of the
Poor People's Campaign and we should
make them visible and define citizenship
from there so I think that would in that
sense it it could be a catalyst for
another movement I hope that's true
please thank Taylor branch for coming to
Los Angeles today come on LA thank
Taylor branch for being here
thank the LA Times and the Festival of
Books and thank c-span for covering this
session we will see you in the south
signing area at line-x the south side a
area and line-x we're headed there right
now thank you all for coming very much